hello hello everyone my name is Philippe
pepper
and they we are going to play with
OpenCV a little bit and then we are
going to see how to have effective it
extract image features react by data
also 2019 it's December 13th quick of
topic today it's Friday
and many people protest against climate
changes happening charondas I believe
that time for action is now and we asked
data developers can deliver a
significant message based on signals
that planet Earth sends to us every day
what ok today we are going to work on
computer vision problems and somehow
go-to solution is to throw never let net
on it and wait what happens today we are
going to use slightly different method
and we will use OpenCV to extract
features I prepared two projects for
this talk first one is a project where
we will detect street lines and the
second one in the second project we will
build build a script that will decide
whether there is a car in front of us or
not so what you'll learn today you will
see what there are image color spaces
and how you can convert them what's
image filtering especially in the
context of color filtering order image
automatic so how you can add subtract
images what's how we can reduce noise in
your new data set which is image what is
edge detection how you can detect edges
and based on edges how you can calculate
lines
what's motion detection especially in
the context of the video and consecutive
frames coming in sequence and at the end
we'll see how we can create the famous
bounding boxes that you probably see in
every computer vision visualization
starting for from the first project
Street line detection the puff is the
following
first we will detect left lane which is
yellow secondly we will detect right
lane which is white then we will reduce
image noise then detect edges and
finally we will create a logic to decide
if something is Street line or not
okay so you read an image and image is
basically a three-dimensional nine
putnam by ra and probably you're most
familiar with the BGR or RGB color space
the shortcut stands for red green blue
and you can think of it as a
three-dimensional coral space where zero
zero point is black color and 255 255
255 is white color so any combination
any color that you can think of always
lays between these two points
and with this approach this is not a
very intuitive approach and there's
sometimes come problems imagine that you
would like to filter the whole yeah
yellow color space probably you start
from light yellow which is 255 255 0
then you will move to the darker darker
color 204 204 0 so one can come up with
a logic that yellow starts at 204 and
ends at 255 but actually if you if we
apply this we get something that is
completely not yellow hmm so HSV color
space comes to the rescue
it's more human intuitive and it has
free channels that responsible for
completely maybe not completely but very
different things first channel is a huge
channel where we have the whole color
palette and it starts at 0 and sad 179
so any color you can think of you can
always be sure that if you select the
appropriate range will be their second
channel is a subtle a saturation which
tells us how faded our our color is so 0
it's completely faded 255 it's not faded
at all and by the way this is you can
think of it as a percentage scale and
this first channel is a brightness
Channel which tells us how much black
color our our Cole has so let's let's
start coding let's read our image in
open CV and as you can see there are
one-liners thanks to which we can read
an image and then we can convert convert
our color from the RGB color space which
is a different default
to the HSV color space then we define
our lower and upper range for the yellow
color by specifying the the list with
free integers and then we use the in
range OpenCV function where especially
where we give input image our lower and
upper boundary and though you can see
the result here if you go to the right
lane which is a white one you basically
see the output of the same operation and
this is usually what you will have once
you start working on your first image
processing project apart from the
section of the image that it's
interesting to you you will have a lot
of noise I mean every data set has a lot
of noise but lucky there luckily there
are many methods to to overcome this
obstacle so I wanted to firstly
introduce erosion what's erosion s in
its basic form it has three parameters
input image even the image from the
previous slide the kernel which is a
square that we slide from the left to
the right from the top to the bottom we
specify the size of this kernel and what
erosion does it diminishes the effects
of peak Scott Y of white pixels that lay
on the on the boundaries of our shape so
basically it slides the kernel if all
pixels are white in the kernel it sets
the center value as a white pixel if
there is at least one black pixel in our
kernel then the return value will be
black the opposite operation is dilation
when when we also also slide the kernel
through it and this time the kernel
checks if all pixels within the kernel
are black if all are black the result is
a blight pixel if there is at least one
white pixel the result will be the white
color and the iteration iteration
parameter sorry it tells you how many
times this operation should be done the
method for reducing false positives from
your data set is opening so it's this is
erosion followed by dilation
so it will quickly let you reduce the
effect of white pixels that you can see
on the left and the opposite operation
when we reduce false negatives is
closing so it reduces the the pixels
that are black within our object so
coming back to our coming back to our
project we apply erosion on our image so
hopefully you remember that we had some
red pixels on the top part of the image
so we managed to reduce majority of
these as always if you increase the
number of iteration in this erosion
procedure probably at the very end you
will have completely black image so once
we have our left lane candidate right
Lane candidate we want to combine this
into one image so you see OpenCV add
function and a quick note here we used
addition in OpenCV it's because it's a
saturated addition so as you remember
from the beginning I suspect I told you
that we usually start on the zero value
in color space and we end on 255 so
that's exactly what addition what's
saturated addition does if we add 240
and 20 the result will be 255 as there
is a floor in the ceiling in our image
values so once we have our combined
results we would like to detect edges
and we are used a canny edge detection
in its in its basic form so we provide
free values our input image the
threshold one and threshold two how can
i edge detection works firstly it
applies Gaussian filter it's another
another filter that helps us to reduce
noise then the pixel gradient strength
and direction are calculated what speaks
our gradient you can think of it as a
rapid change from the white to black
color this is going to be very high
gradient white white each color is not
not white greatness is not high gradient
then we normalize each candidates so if
you imagine the
image the edge is always a transition
period but we are interested in very
sharp edges so there are always gradient
candidates for deciding if something is
an edge or not so basically the from the
candidates we choose the maximum value
and then we apply the threshold in
parameters
so if gradient is the value of the
gradient is above the second threshold
the pixel is going to be considered an
edge if value is between first and
second threshold it depends whether
algorithm previously classified the
neighboring pixels as edges or not and
in a last case if the gradient is below
the threshold
the value of the pixel is not going to
be considered an edge so this is the
result of our edge detection clearly we
can see the left and right lane are
detected and based on that this'll still
pixels so we don't have any
understanding whether there are lines in
our image or not so we are going to use
pupil probabilistic function it's
probabilistic function because it only
considers a subset of your data set from
the points that you've seen on the
previous slide it has a lot of
parameters I know but stay with me okay
so firstly we need to define what the
line is you of course know that the line
equation in Cartesian coordinates but
also we can represent line in polar
coordinates where we have two crucial
parameters which is Rho which is a
distance from the coordinate system and
theta which is an angle with horizontal
axis so what hew probabilistic function
does is basically let's imagine that
white points are our edges so it loops
over all possible lines in our image and
we specify the loop step by specifying
Rho and theta parameter in our function
and it starts classifying the lines and
calculates how many points overlay with
our overlay with our line so for the
first line we have zero points that
coincide if you consider the second line
we have one point that coincides and for
the last time we have three points that
coincides so basically this
this is how you get intuition what the
line is and this is why use fresh hold
parameter by specifying fresh holes if
we specified threshold parameter equal
to three and then the last line would be
considered as a line and the previous
two wouldn't be considered lines the
last two parameters minimum line length
specify what's the minimum length of the
line in pixels for the line to be
considered as one and the max line gap
prevents us from lines being concluded
so imagine that if we have a line here
you take a picture somewhere from
somewhere there and then for this for
the short part even image the line is
not visible then it continues so this is
exactly why we have this much slime gap
parameter to prevent us from from the
occurrences like this so we did detected
lines in our image and this is the
perfect moment to invite you to write
logic about determining if something is
a straight line or not so invite you to
visit my repository I uploaded the whole
code before my presentation so you can
see what is the logic for determining
determining if something is a straight
line or not so in that method is basic
Python and we check whether the line has
a straight line characteristics such as
length direction with the horizontal
axis or the or the width and once we
apply everything what we combine combine
all the procedures we have our results
so as you can see the left and right
line are detected quite good second
project second exercise for this talk
the motion detectors so that the
procedure is the following from now on
you should think of the any video as a
sequence of images that we can analyze
in loop so for our project we are going
to take a first frame of the video where
we know that there is nothing in front
of us and we are going to consider it as
a template for every next frame we will
compare compare and calculate the pixel
difference and then we are also going to
consider only area limit
by street lines that we calculated in
the previous exercise and for the large
group of pixels that change for the
large intensities we are going to we are
going to assume that this is a car that
it's likely moving in front of us so we
start from reading our image but then we
know that for this exercise we don't
have to calculate it in a three
dimensional space so we convert it to
grayscale color space the advantage of
converting image of to the grayscale is
of course that we have less data to
analyze so everything computes faster
but we also lose some important
information that for example you're able
to use in the previous exercise then we
apply blaring what's blaring we our
images come in sequence and for example
there is a lot of noise that comes here
and there the buildings on the left size
can change the left side can change the
whole environment can change and what
blaring does it basically normalizes
that the images that come in sequence
how blaring does we specify the kernel
size and within that kernel we sum all
the pixel and we calculate the mean
value and we set it as a center value
for the pixel then we calculate absolute
difference we subtract our current frame
from the template that we set at the
beginning of the video and then we mask
our and the result of the of that
operation is presented on the left
what's the center image it's our mask so
this is our region of interest we want
to only consider changes in that area
and we use B twice and in OpenCV handy
method to basically tell okay I only
want to use the the area from the left
image that is highlighted in the center
image so the result you can see the
result on the on the right side so once
again grayscale image values from 0 to
251 and this is when we we know that for
example for this pedestrian lines we
don't want to consider this as a change
we only want to consider it
some there is a rapid change in our
image so this is when we use the
threshold function in the fresh hold
function we apply the threshold value so
we say if the pixel is below below the
threshold value is going to be equal to
zero if it's higher than threshold value
is going to be equal to max value and we
specify this type of fresh holding by by
saying okay we want to have binary
threshold so in our output image we are
only going to have two values of pixels
possible then as we can see on the Left
we have three white areas visible so the
next part is going to be finding
contours what our contours as name says
is basically the line that and frames
the area so we calculate contours and in
the find contours method we specify what
kind of contour we are interested in so
in our case we are interested in
external contours and we are going also
going to tell to OpenCV okay we want to
as a return value we want to have very
specific very precise representation of
our contour you can also tell that you
want to simplify this and for example as
a result only get a rectangle for values
of points that are going to and frame
your contour and then we get our
contours and for these contours we
calculate the area at the pixel area of
the contour the next step we filtered so
we set a threshold if the rapid change
was above a certain threshold this is
likely a car and for that we finally
draw draw a rectangle and in OpenCV you
draw a rectangle by specifying was the
top-left corner of the rectangle and
bottom right corner you can also specify
its color and thickness of course so
this is the result we detected car in
front of us and we are also able to
detect that car disappears so basically
there is a clear low road in front of us
but beware because light has changed so
we cannot move further
so as a summary we've done a lot today
sometimes the this is a whole the whole
udemy course so hopefully you're
satisfied first we've seen what are the
color spaces was BGR color space what
HSV color space and how you can quickly
convert these and why you can sometimes
consider using one color space in place
of a default one then we've seen what's
image masking and especially and also
we've seen what's image filtering based
on color values we also have seen what's
how you can add and subtract images
white saturation saturated operation
then we seen what are the four methods
in open CV that can help you reduce
noise coming in your image so we defined
erosion we defined dilation opening and
closing then we then we search for edges
in our image and based on edges with
edges we calculated lines that are there
then we analyzed the video in the
context of motion detection and
comparison of the values that change
rapidly finally we've seen image fresh
holding methods and we also seen how we
can create bounding boxes my subjective
tips for you hopefully you'll start your
first project in open CV so display
every result this is way of debugging
open CV code and in my opinion this is
the ideal way of checking whether the
operation that you applied is
appropriate and worked properly second
playing with metered parameters
understand parameters don't go with
default ones really sometimes by
changing for example the in the
probabilistic function by changing the
step size you can speed up computation
time significantly which for example
matters when you run some operation in
someone's browser and finally simple is
better than complex so before going with
neural nets start with something simple
that you can do in open CV in a few
lines or slightly more than few
check the results validate your results
and if this doesn't work of course go if
something more complicated what's next
there are really great tutorials
tutorials provided by open CV community
so I invite you to check there check the
documentation see their tutorials
of course the whole source code input
images video and the whole talk will be
is already uploaded to my github
repository so I invite you to go there
download and finally the best way to
learn something is by starting your
first project so go ahead and and create
your first computer vision system from
time to time I write blog post regarding
data science machine learning computer
vision data engineering so if you want
to read some free tutorials I invite you
to go to my blog and sign up to my
newsletter so that you are always up to
date with what's new there and as always
stay in contact on Twitter and let's
talk to each other thank you very much